it feels so nice to be finishing here in
Kingston Penitentiary telling grace
Marc's story it's very meaningful to
know that she was she was here at a time
as well it's all kind of setting in the
the reality of it the difficulty the
despair all of that it's been actually
pretty heavy there's no substitute for
being in in the real place with these
terrible things happen and where the
real grace Marx was in this very prison
so this morning arriving on set I
couldn't stop thinking its grace Marx
was here I have been an inmate for 15
long years there's been a crime people
want a guilty person
rightly or wrongly does not matter you
want to do that person justice and their
memory justice and then what happened to
them so I'm yeah it's been it's been
really heavy heavier than I think I
anticipated I think that the whole
project is a big exploration on female
identity which was why I was so drawn to
it to be able to go to work every day
and say you know words at Margaret
Atwood wrote has been the experience of
a lifetime
you
[Music]